okay we're all excited that CS2 is
finally here but now that we're out of
beta there's no more excuses and the
game still just doesn't seem like it's
up to par sure it's way less buggy than
it was and valve have made huge strides
in terms of improving the overall game
play but the game just still feels wrong
CS2 is upon us but what if it wasn't
ready to be upon us
before we dive in an extremely topical
reminder that we have a face it clan
that's right you can join for free using
the link in the description below and
play with me your friends and the rest
of our community as we climb the
leaderboards collect points and spend
them in the shop fa its's new CS2
infrastructure has a ton of new features
so check it out okay so today we're
going to do a review of CS2 it is a
video game after all and that is a thing
that people do with video games
especially when they officially launch
which is exactly what happened earlier
this week CS2 replaced csgo on Steam and
became available to everyone as
essentially a free franchise altering
updates to the existing iteration of
Counter-Strike which means it is going
to start being subjected to a higher
level of scrutiny valve were the ones
who said summer 2023 that was their call
that was their decision and to be fair
they lived up to it well I mean like
they missed it by a few days but you
know close enough so let's talk about it
the nitty-gritty what's good what's bad
and what has to get better for starters
what is CS2 well it's a patch a very
very big patch they literally took
Global Offensive ported it over to
Source 2 redid the maps to varying
degrees and overhauled the basic
functionality of the utility so when we
talk about whether CS2 is good or bad
what we're really talking about is
whether it feels and function functions
better or worse than Global Offensive a
game that valve tuned to Perfection over
the course of a decade and right now CS2
feels worse than csgo but it functions
better I'll explain what I mean by that
let's start with what is basically the
biggest change that CS2 brings to the
table the utility in CS2 nades are both
Dynamic and responsive mollies and HS
don't make it harder to see smoke
grenades are more well defined and
expand to fill the space they're thrown
into bullets help carve spaces in smokes
and hes temporarily dispel them valve's
goal was to add strategic depth and
while it's hard to definitively say
whether they succeeded since we haven't
seen any pro play yet I can tell you
that from my experience playing the game
the utility feels so much better to use
everything surrounding the utility
touch-ups in CS2 is fantastic and bound
to shake things up for the better on
that front valve outdid themselves and
the competition but of equal importance
is the fact that it fixed all of the
super busted spaghetti code nonsense
surrounding utility that over the years
came to Define The Meta in csgo the best
example of which are one ways yes they
got rid of one ways basically in csgo
players learned that throwing utility in
the right spots would let you create
scenarios where you could see your
opponents but they couldn't see you it
basically meant that it even a medium
level of play outcomes hinged on
completely unfair gunfights now are
there still ways to abuse obfuscated
sight lines using smokes and CS2 yes and
we're already seeing some of them come
to light but there are way fewer of them
and the sight lines they create are way
less broken one of the reasons for this
is that CS2 isn't trying to look as
realistic as CS go CS2 is a way way
brighter clearer and smoother looking
game than Global Offensive ever was the
textures have been streamlined and the
dingy ass Corners that litter every map
have been illuminated look you can make
fun of the valerant child game aesthetic
all you want one of the best things
about CS2 is how easy it is to see
people and the fact that it allows aim
to be the determining factor in the vast
majority of gunfights to me this is the
foundation that will eventually turn CS2
into a masterpiece every aesthetic and
mechanical decision was made to make CS2
a fairer version of Cs go no more
one-ways no more hard to see BS just
real honest to God Counterstrike two
players their guns May the best aimer
win but valve didn't stop there they
took all of the ancillary stuff Maps
weapon skins weapon sounds and either
overhauled them streamlined them or
simply made them prettier CS2 is somehow
simultaneously csgo on steroids and with
the sharp edges shaved off it is the
Counterstrike that we as a community
both wanted and needed the new player
experience for instance has been greatly
improved not only have valve added a
real tutorial called Training Day
they've also streamlined jump throws so
new players don't have to do a bunch of
Googling and console command nonsense
before loading into a game valve have
also switched the game to 24 round Maps
down from the 30 rounds of csgo so far
it actually feels pretty good leading to
snappier faster paced games but there
are some problems mostly that valve
haven't made any economic adjustments to
offset the shorter match structure loss
bonuses will almost certainly need an
adjustment especially as Pros begin to
explore this new format all in all
Counter-Strike 2 is a remarkable
achievement it looks better functions
better and is built on a more rugged
sophisticated infrastructure but it
doesn't feel better at least not yet but
this is in news all right for months
those with access to the limited beta
have been complaining about how awful
CS2 feels the movement the spraying the
hit RG tick rate net code all of it and
rightfully so the game has to varying
degrees felt like in a word dog
[__] what there are a lot of problems
the guns aren't as precise as they
should be the movement isn't sharp
spraying sometimes results and you just
not hitting anything at
all what is this spray it's hard to
quantify but trust me when you play it
you'll feel it it's loose and imprecise
and in a game like this that's a huge
problem please just die please just die
I hate the spraying I hate the spraying
so much now valve have made some
substantial changes already and the game
does feel a lot better than it used to
in fact this past week when they
launched the game officially they made
further adjustments did those
adjustments make a difference well it
depends on who you ask personally I
think it feels sort of worse but a lot
of other people seem to think it feels
better either way the point is that
valve is trying to fix this problem but
the important thing to understand is
that CS2 categorically does not feel as
good as csgo did on 1286 servers but it
took valve over 10 years to get CSG go
into that place which leads me to the
point of this review CS2 doesn't feel as
good yet it will feel better than csgo
eventually csgo is and let's just be
honest here the most important
influential and yes best shooter ever
made it just is the game itself was a
disaster there were countless things
about it that drove us crazy but what it
did for TAC FPS can never never be
replicated and that game the Undisputed
goat was a hot mess when valve first put
it into beta but over time it got better
much better valve turned around a game
that a lot of people didn't think was
salvageable it's going to take time for
CS2 to become what it needs to be and
unfortunately I can't sit here and
whisper sweet nothings about how it'll
take no time at all I don't know how
long it'll take what I do know is that
the issues that people have with CS2
aren't design related the way they were
with source and even early csgo valve
have learned a lot since then and know
what it takes to produce a First Rate
Counterstrike and presumably how to do
it faster than before so if you're
sitting there wondering what the verdict
is on
CS2 it's great but with a big asterisk I
think you should be playing it now not
that you have a choice but even if you
did have a choice you should be playing
it because you want to be on the ground
floor of the next best shooter ever
made thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite-size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit us up on our
Twitter Instagram Facebook and Tik
[Music]
Tok